you all need to respect the impossible
man check this out so the impossible man
can change his shape and form into
anything he wants with no limit to what
he can become he can change his size
from exceedingly small to impossibly
large he can fly by changing his body
into a flying form his strength and
durability increase with his size the
impossible man can project powerful
energy blast he can turn invisible at
will he can heal from any injury he's
Immortal and cannot be killed he can
teleport himself and others across space
and time he has the ability to
manipulate reality to a certain extent
but this ability is not really as
powerful as other Cosmic entities the
impossible man can copy the powers of
others with no defined limit and he can
adapt to any environment under any
conditions make sure you guys follow for
more